You might be enticed to start your
design work for larger screens.
After all, everyone has these humongous
phones and tablet's these days, right?
While the average size of phones and
tablet's is growing,
we're going to consciously design for
the smaller sizes first.
If you design an interface for
a phone screen,
it's still usable on a tablet screen.
It might have lots of white space and
look odd, but
the app will still work fine.
Now you can't see the same for
a tablet UI viewed on a phone.
That'd be really hard to use,
all those little touch targets.
Starting with small screens also
really helps you simplify and
prioritize what should go into the UI.
At each step we want to carefully
consider which elements, if any,
to add to larger screens.